(footsteps)
- Hey Justin, ready to go see San Andreas?
- Oh man, I forgot I actually
made plans with Quinta
to see San Andreas.
She loves the Rock.
- Uh yeah, that's cool.
I mean we all love the Rock.
- Yeah, hey, but raincheck though?
I'll watch it again with you.
- Okay.
- [Justin] All right. (laughs)
- Can't wait.
Have fun.
(comical yet regal music)
(squeaking)
(pants)
- Hey Justin, ready to
go play some basketball?
- Uh sorry man, I promised Quinta
I'd play racketball with her.
- Quinta, oh ok, cool.
- You could come, if you want.
- Nah, it's okay, you
know I don't like rackets.
- Raincheck then?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- I'll see ya later.
- Cool.
I hope you have a bad ankle injury.
- What was that?
- I said have a great time.
- All right, hey bye.
- Hey yo, Chef Curry.
You ready for Smoked Salmon Saturday?
- I'm sorry, Zack, I'm actually doing
Sirloin Souffle Saturdays with Quinta.
- Sirloin Souffle, it's
like a meat in a pastry?
- She's a great cook.
- (chuckles sarcastically)
Sounds like it, cool.
- Raincheck?
- Yeah, let's raincheck.
- All right. (laughing)
- [Zack] Sounds good, see ya later.
I hope you burn your meat.
- Wait, what?
- Uh, I hope you meet her family.
- Cool man, see ya.
- (sighs) Do, do do.
All right, Justin, you ready for Hawaii?
- Oh man, I'm sorry I completely forgot.
I made plans to go to the
Caribbean with Quinta.
- Justin we already have tickets.
- I know, can you like sell
them on Craigslist or something?
- I don't think that's how it works,
your name is on the ticket!
- I, just, find another
Justin Tan, there are tons.
- I don't want another Justin Tan.
I want this Justin Tan.
(sad music)
- How about we hang out when I get back?
All right?
- You actually promise this time?
- I promise.
- Okay.
- (sighs) I'll see ya later.
- 'Kay.
I hope she gets bit by a shark.
- Wait, what?
- I said she's a lucky and lovely girl.
- Thanks.
All right.
- [Zack] But I hope
she gets bit by a shark.
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)